alors non je ne me présenterai pas aux
municipales l'ancien maire daniel paris
ce débarqué en juin dernier jette
l'épongé il souhaite pour hôtes ont
continué à peser dans le débat mais
d'une autre manière après les élections
je reviendrai je vais organiser et
structurer lancé un signe donc la borat
ward idée où toutes les nuances
toutes les expertises seront les
bienvenus daniel paris ce en dehors de
la mêlée on aurait pu imaginer que des
rivalités s'apaise dans le camp de la
gauche il n'en est rien c'est même pire
qu'avant dans cette ville de 28 mille
habitants il y aura quatre listes de
gauche le sortant michel faou réélu en
août à la surprise générale la rapide
mais il donne franchement l'impression
d'y aller à contre coeur il faut y aller
mais bon je suis d'un naturel plutôt
pessimiste au départ mais rapidement ça
repart
mais bon c'est vrai que avoir
cinq six peut-être cette liste c'est
pour une bonne chose
peut-être pour la démocratie d'ailleurs
face à lui son adversaire d'il ya six
mois francine weecksteen cette proche de
daniel paris ce sont ses distances avec
l'ancien maire et présente une liste
d'ouverture apolitique je les réunis à
la fois des personnes plutôt de droit
plutôt de gauche dont je ne connais pas
l'engagement politique nationale mais
qui en tout cas ont le souci de
s'investir pour leur ville comme je lé
fais depuis six ans avec certains de mes
collègues qui sont autour de moi
aujourd'hui troisième candidat pascal
simon il est le moins connu des têtes de
listes de gauche mais il est le
représentant du parti socialiste au
milieu de ce capharnaüm c'est au moins
un positionnement lisible pour les
électeurs non considère que nous sommes
la liste à gauche ou non concurrence se
définit sa politique aux centristes et
on a la légitimité c'est à dire qu'on
est
nous dans le combat depuis 2008 nous
étions candidats une équipe quasiment
identique et on s'est mis très vite dans
les positions daniel parisse on part sur
nos valeurs enfin le front de gauche est
également en lice il faut encore ajouter
une liste centre-droit et bien sûr le
front national emmené par edouard
ferrand un éparpillement des voix de
gauche et une multiplicité de candidats
qui semblent en tout cas ouvrir un
boulevard à la liste ump qui sera selon
toute probabilité emmenée par l'ancien
maire et députée marie louise fort